synchronic seems to blend a lot of
different genres how are you how would
you describe this movie do you want to
take a [ __ ] okay me yeah I will I got
Amelie comedy synchronic is about two
paramedics in New Orleans who have been
friends for a very long time played by
Jamie Dornan and Anthony Mackie and they
stumble across these first responder
calls that are very grisly and strange
they don't seem to make any sense and
they're all linked by this one designer
drug called synchronic and which is
which is the name of the movie right and
so Ali playing his daughter that he had
very young important note she apparently
takes the drug and then disappears so
how would you describe the
father-daughter relationship in this
film before she disappears well it's um
it's it's it's kind of beautiful I think
their relationship you know one I feel
like it's feels sort of very necessary
that we've just all so we have a baby in
the movie as well and this was a huge
age gap so you're you know Dennis is
going through this crazy sort of time
with dealing with a newborn baby but
then he also has to deal with everything
that having a sort of 18 year old
daughter Brittany no she's not old is
she 18 18 I say I'm I'm not gonna say
the lines everything that that is and
the different scales of parenting a
newborn and parenting a young adult and
yeah I think I'm allowed to say that um
Ali's character was missing as a result
of this designer drug and that just
froze Genesis world into total chaos so
what was it that attracted you both to
the roles um I just read the script and
actually can I say that well I'm just I
that like Brianna was supposed to be a
guy at first yes
so like when I was auditioning part he
was like Brian and like all this sides
are Brian he was like what up and I and
I think that I liked that I think that I
was like oh sick like this would be like
a cool challenge like I'm like kind of
playing a guy but it's a girl and then I
just I just really like the script and
then I just thought that she seems like
someone that like I could relate to and
put myself into that just seemed like
really full and like real like a real
girl in college like dealing with like
you know like having a dad that's like a
bit distant and like having a really
like younger sister like it's just it's
just interesting and I think relatable
for like a lot of people and then for
you Jamie as a parent is that something
that you're able to tap into like the
fear of what you know what having a
missing child having a child in crisis
sure yeah absolutely I mean it changes
your whole perspective on the world
being a father and yes funny it's kind
of the older you get and further on your
career the more father she seemed to
play you know I've never played the
father to such an older okay I have to
say this might be a training for you was
like this is weird but I guess but
that's legit I mean there's people have
kids teenagers you know but yeah I mean
the very thought of that it gives me
nightmares the idea of a kid one of my
kids going missing minutes every
parent's biggest fear so I'm can't
relate to what that actually feels like
but I'm I can relate to the idea of what
it would be like I'm what they would do
to me and why you would spiral out of
control and need everyone and everything
around you to help you and that's a big
part of of this movie is it's a help
that that that they get when Brianna
like was missing and then what was it
like working with Anthony Mackie as
Steve how would you describe your
relationship as characters and as actors
yeah I mean you know it's a thing of
like they're meant to have a long
standing friendship they've been friends
for very long time and then suddenly
you're on set with someone you've met
at once and shared a cigar with and like
something awful
sunset bloomer so la I know all the
street names sunset Avenue it's a great
place on Mackey is a force of nature you
know he brings with him this big you
know masculine bravado energy you know
on to my slightly more meek
mild-mannered energy I take and I love
him I'm a big fan of his his work and I
see very nearly worked with him last
year on something else and then there
was a sort of issue of schedules and
stuff so I was quite glad that I got the
opportunity and um yeah he was
he made it feel very easy you know and I
hope that our friendship feels real you
know you're you're both really good at
faking it being friendly right good for
you we noticed that yes that's our job